Welcome to 3.091.
My name is Donald Sadoway,
and I'll be your lecturer this fall.
We've got plenty of room here if
you need to sit.
You can sit up the steps and in the
aisles. We'll get things sorted out
in the next day or two.
What I'd like to do today is to
introduce myself,
introduce the subject,
introduce my plans.
I have plans for you.
I have plans for you called plans
for learning because that's what
it's all about.
People if you're coming in now,
you can sit up here, or you even can
sit on the floor up here.
It's one big happy family.
So, let me begin by telling you
that 3.091 is the most important
subject that you will take at MIT.
It is the most important subject
that you'll take at MIT.
I truly believe that. But,
you know, any professor who stands
before you should say the same thing
about his or her subject.
If they don't believe that,
they shouldn't be teaching. The
difference is,
when I say it, I'm right.
It is the most important subject.
I want to teach you things that you
are going to retain,
you're going to take with you.
So, we need to get down to that.
What I want to do is get you to
appreciate the unique perspective
that you will get from studying
solid-state chemistry.
And so, what I want to do is begin
by doing a little bit of
introduction so you get to
know what's going on.
So, I'm going to talk a little bit
about myself, about the staff,
and actually if I could ask the
teaching staff to start handing out,
there's three handouts that are
going to come to you.
Just stay seated, we'll get them to
you. If you don't get them,
there's plenty of copies after.
And, we are going to post
everything on the website.
So, let me begin by doing a little
bit of background so you know what's
going on here.
I was born in Canada.
I went to the University of Toronto
and I studied chemical metallurgy.
You might say,
well what's the person who studied
chemical metallurgy doing teaching
chemistry here?
Well, after my Ph.
., I came here as a postdoctoral
fellow in 1977.
The plan was to stay for a year or
two, and then go back to Canada,
and I lost track of time. So, I
joined the faculty in 1978,
and my first teaching assignment was
3.091 recitation.
I had two sections.
One met at 8 am, and one met at 9
am. We don't have 8 am sections,
at least we haven't in recent years.
Maybe it's time to revisit that.
So, my research is electrochemistry.
That's why I'm teaching chemistry.
Electrochemistry is the most
important branch of chemistry.
Why not?
Find your passion and pursue it.
So, I'm interested in nonaqueous
electrochemistry.
I don't care about water.
I'm interested in nonaqueous
electrochemistry,
so molten salts and polymers,
the applied research. First of all,
interested in environmentally sound
technologies for extraction,
refining, recycling of metals.
It's all chemical processes.
Second, pardon me, second
is batteries.
I want to have an all-electric
vehicle in my lifetime.
I want to see the end of the
internal combustion engine applied
to personal mobility.
The only thing that stands between
us and that is a suitable battery.
So, find an important problem.
Work on it, and to say nothing of
the wireless device there.
She's driving, and she's talking on
the cell phone, and looking
at the photographer.
And last one, we have to dream.
We have to dream beyond the
day-to-day living.
Let's talk about the stars.
So, if we're going to go to the
moon, we're going to go to Mars,
we want to be able to produce oxygen,
structural metals and photovoltaic
materials from in situ resources.
So, I have some research on that,
as well. So, that's the kind of
stuff: a little bit of background
about myself.
So now, let's talk about the
perspective of 3.
91. All of this will be posted.
You can take notes. You can just
enjoy. You don't have to worry
about getting tested on this
material, at least not on my life
story. That would be too
self-serving. So,
if you look at any engineering
system, the performance of that
engineering system is a function of
its design and its construction.
And, that can be anything from a
computer to a living system.
We are solid-state devices.
We are made of soft matter.
This is macromolecular chemistry.
These are photodetectors, band gap
two electron volts,
respond to visible light.
They're not made of gallium
arsenide. They are made of organic
matter: the same rules,
the same laws of chemistry that
apply to what makes this laser glow
green apply to what makes these
photodetectors work.
Well, what about construction?
Construction is a combination of
workmanship and choice of materials.
Take this computer, if I pull the
silicon out, I replace it with
gallium arsenide,
leave everything else the same.
Gallium arsenide switches ten times
faster than silicon.
All of a sudden, I've got a clock
speed ten times faster with no
change in design.
So, that's the power of the choice
of materials, and why?
Properties. Materials are bundles
of properties.
Conceptually, they are bundles of
properties.
What is this? You say it's an
aluminum can. No,
it's a bundle of properties.
This is a beverage container.
I could make this out of
borosilicate glass.
I could make this out of polymer.
I could make this out of metal. I
could even make it out of steel
versus aluminum.
I could make it out of titanium if
I wanted. I could make it out of
gold. I'd prefer to make it out of
platinum if I had my way. Why?
Bundle of properties: mechanical
strength, chemical inertness,
ease of fabrication: that's not a
unique solution.
Cost, ah, there is a factor that
may be a determinant.
So, properties, and where do we get
properties from?
Here: composition,
clearly. Everybody knows that.
If you change the composition, you
change the properties.
But this is different.
What I'm going to tell you now is
different.
why you take 3.
91. The properties are not only a
function of composition.
They are a function of the instant
atomic arrangement,
how we arrange the atoms: same
composition, simple example,
one inch thick pine board, one inch
thick plywood.
Both made of pine; both one inch
thick.
Which one has the superior
mechanical properties?
The plywood. Why? Because the
plywood has been sliced into thin
pieces that are laminated
cross-grain. So,
composition alone can't give you the
answer to the question,
why is the plywood superior to the
solid pine board?
It has to be the atomic arrangement.
The thesis of 3.
91, and this is where the chemistry
comes in, is that electronic
structure of the elements holds the
key to the understanding,
not just the chemical bonding,
but the long range atomic order.
So, that's how we get to the
syllabus. So,
here's the syllabus: two big blocks,
first block general principles of
chemistry, and that's the same
whether you take 3.
91 or 5.111 or 5.112.
This is your insurance policy.
This is what ensures that if you
take 3.091, you can go on
later and take 5.12.
You could be a chemical engineer.
You can go to medical school. And
then, this is the specialty topics
that pertain to the devices,
engineering systems. So, let's turn
to the handouts now.
What I'm going to do for about the
next 15-20 minutes is just tell you
what the class operation is like so
everybody knows.
I want you to understand what
you've signed up for.
The text is the one shown here.
It's out in second edition. It's
available at The Coop.
It's available at Quantum Books.
There's even some first editions
out there which are very,
very similar. There are some minor
differences. There's some numbering
differences with some of the
homework problems.
I don't care if you buy the book.
I don't work for Wiley. I don't
own shares in Wiley.
I don't own shares in The Coop.
I don't care if you buy the book.
If you want the book, that's the
book I use.
Lectures, lectures are Monday,
Wednesday, Friday at 11:00, or
Monday, Wednesday,
Friday at 1:00. The enrollment,
last time I looked, is an even 600.
So, the registrar's computer
divided you between this 11:00
lecture and the 1:00 lecture.
If you want to change lectures,
please go to Hillary or Lori, and
arrange it because as you can see,
some people don't have a seat.
If everybody goes to the assigned
place, there will be a seat for
everybody. So,
out of courtesy,
I think it's important that we
follow the assignment.
So, if you want to go at 1:00,
you're welcome to do so, but please
arrange it with my assistants.
The 1:00 lecture is smaller group.
It's about 150. And, it's around
the corner on the first floor
building, 6-120.
So, 11:00 will be in 10-250,
and 1:00 will be in 6-120.
So, that's Monday,
Wednesday, Friday, and that's the
standard lecture format: I talk,
you listen. I'm going to write
things on the board,
I'm going to post things up on the
screen, and so on.
Where you get a chance to interact
on a greater level is in the
recitations. The recitation is an
old, archaic, New England term.
If you go back to the colonial times,
education would be conducted in an
unheated room by someone who
basically hates children and would
come into the room and look at
someone, and glower and yell,
"Sadoway! Stand and recite!" I
would recite, whatever,
the Articles of Confederation.
I would rise on my hind legs,
quaking in my boots,
and I would begin until I made a
mistake, whereupon I would be
castigated, berated,
totally stripped of self-esteem by
this monster who would that inflict
the same pain on somebody else.
That was education in the old days.
We are going to do it a little
differently this year.
So, in your recitations sections,
I have asked the instructors not to
do that. Instead,
you come to class. You control the
agenda. I have instructed them not
to give you a fourth and fifth
lecture. You come there with your
questions. You come to my lectures,
take some notes, maybe you don't
record everything I say.
Maybe record what you didn't
understand. Then you go to
recitation. The first thing they
are supposed to say is good morning
or good afternoon,
and then they say, what are your
questions?
And, they draw up the agenda.
So, someone says I didn't
understand what he was talking about
at the end of the last lecture when
he was doing the Bohr model.
I didn't get it. Somebody else
will say, can you do number three on
the homework for me?
So, they draw up the agenda, OK?
So, those recitations occur Tuesdays
and Thursday. So,
you'll have a time,
and you'll go to the same time on
the Tuesday and on the Thursday.
The same thing applies here as with
the lectures. If you wish to change
sections, you may do so only with
permission of the subject
administrators because it's very
important that those sections be
kept at a small population.
I want to have the population at a
number no greater than 20.
That way you get good access to the
TA.
I don't want to have a section with
30 in it. So,
there are many sections.
They run from nine in the morning
through four in the afternoon with
multiple sections through the middle
of the day, which are the most
popular sections.
And, if you'd like to change,
you can do so only with the
permission of the administrator.
And, you have to have reason to do
so. You can't do it because,
I don't do mornings or because my
girlfriend is in this other section.
No, I don't get freedom; I'm told I
have to be here at 11:00 Monday,
Wednesday, and Friday.
I can't go down to the registrar and
say, you know,
I'd really like to do it at another
time. No, no.
But if you have a UROP,
or you have a sports practice or
something, we will allow that.
So, please stick to the sections.
And, right now, because of
burgeoning enrollment,
we've opened up some sections.
So, these three are underpopulated.
So, if you'd like to switch into
one of these three,
they have very low numbers right now.
We've added an extra one at 11:00,
an extra one at 2:00, and we've
added one at 1:00.
So, if that meets your schedule in
a better manner,
then again, do it but only with
permission from Hillary or Lori.
Oh, by the way, talking about under
enrolled subjects,
the complementary subject offered by
STS called History,
Society, and Solid State Chemistry
meets Tuesdays and Thursdays at
11:00 in room 2-136.
It is underpopulated right now,
so if you are still shopping for a
humanities subject,
this one bears the precious CI-H
designation. Think about that.
If it's a question about the time
of that, then perhaps raise it with
the instructor and see,
you know, we are talking about a
small number of people.
I suspect that enrollment is going
to be in the dozens,
so it could easily be rearranged if
the time is conflicting with one of
your other classes.
Homework: 3.091 is different.
I give homework as a learning aid.
I give homework, and you'll see you
have homework questions with model
solutions at the outset.
I want you to learn by studying the
homework. I'm not going to have you
work long hours on difficult
problems to be submitted and then
graded. I don't do that.
Part of this is designed to get you
to start thinking about the
transition from high school to
college. What I mean by that is I
want you to take ownership of your
learning. So,
I'm not going to come around and say,
did you do your homework?
And, I've got evidence that you
didn't do it because you didn't turn
it in. So, it's easy.
It's easy to blow it off.
And those of you who have had a lot
of chemistry, for the first little
while it's going to be a lot of
review, and you're going
to get complacent.
Don't do it. Develop good study
habits. The homework is a good test
of that. Make the time to work the
homework problems.
But just to make sure,
to stimulate interest, every Tuesday
in recitation there'll be a ten
minute quiz based upon the content
of the homework.
So, if you've worked the homework
problems, you will do the homework
quiz handily. If you haven't looked
at the homework problems,
you might have difficulty with the
homework quiz.
So, there is no homework grade
based on turning homework in.
The homework portion of your total
grade is the aggregate of all of
those weekly test scores.
And, you must take the test.
If you fail to take the test,
you get zero, and I average the zero
in. If you don't make it to class,
contact your TA, your recitation
instructor, and you can take a
makeup within a week of the time of
original test.
I want to give you every chance to
get caught up, but it's
your education.
I want you to take ownership of it.
So, all scores count. There's no
dropping of lowest scores from the
average. Some of the other classes
perhaps do this.
People have actually confronted me
telling me it's an MIT rule.
I've been here 26 years. I know
what the rules are.
Speaking of homework,
here's homework number one.
So, it's assigned today.
You've got the model solutions,
and there will be a test in
recitation on Tuesday the 14th based
upon that homework.
And, it's based upon the homework
subject. So, I don't want somebody
coming in with an attorney saying,
well, the question looked a little
bit like 39, but it's not exactly.
Well, I think you know what I'm
saying. Let's continue with the
administration.
In addition to the weekly homeworks,
there will be monthly tests.
And they've all been scheduled.
So, you can plan. The monthly
tests are the following dates:
September 29, October 27,
November 17. The tests will be
written in the normal class period.
Now, I know you've had all this
bonding in the orientation period,
but I think that it's much better
when you write a test for there to
be some solid state defects known as
vacancies in between
the various people.
So, on the day of the test,
we will have a shadow rooms.
And we will divide you. So,
some of you will write in here,
and some of you will write in some
of the other rooms.
But you will write during the
normal class period.
It will run the 50 minutes.
And, likewise, there will be a test
running from 1:05 to 1:55: two
different tests of comparable
difficulty. I did this last year,
and the difference in the scores on
all three tests was less than 1%.
So, I think we are capable of,
with the kind of assistance of my
staff capable of setting exams of
comparable difficulty.
But again, you are going to be
required to go to the room that
you've been assigned.
Otherwise, we don't have enough
seats, or we don't have enough test
papers and so on.
By the way, on the tests,
you will be getting tomorrow these
handouts that you can use in working
the homeworks,
so when you are taking the test,
you are allowed to bring in the copy
of the periodic table
of the elements.
We give you a very rich table of
constants that's got all kinds of
things from the mass of the electron
to the speed of light,
and all this stuff to the requisite
number of significant figures.
And, in addition, you are allowed
to take in one sheet of paper,
one sheet 8 1/2 x 11, you can write
anything you want on it.
You can write on the front; you can
write on the back.
You can write on the edge for all I
care. You can write; you can print.
I've seen students photocopy exams
down to the size of a postage stamp.
I don't care what you write on
there. What it's designed to do is
to give you the resources you think
you need so that I can focus on
measuring whether you've learned
anything as opposed to whether
you've remembered,
memorized anything,
OK, and of course, something to
calculate with.
There is a final exam in this
subject. It's a three-hour final.
The final exam period is December
13 - 17th this year.
Do not plan to leave town until your
finals are over.
Do not come to your instructor and
say, I've got a really good ticket
but I'm leaving on the 13th.
No, you are here for the finals.
But I will say, once you know your
final exams, schedule.
And, you should know that about
October 1. The registrar will
publish the schedule.
Once you know that, get on the
phone, get on the Internet,
book your tickets. There are 30
degree-granting institutions in the
Boston area. They start at
different times.
They all end just before Christmas.
Everybody and his pet dog is trying
to get a seat on a plane out of
Logan airport.
So, once you know your schedule,
then you make your arrangements.
But you must be here for the final.
Grading: for freshmen, it's pass,
no record. And,
to get a pass as a freshman,
you have to be performing at C level
or better. For upperclassmen,
you get the full range of the
alphabet, A, B,
C, D, F, it's all there,
available for you.
What is the final grade made of?
I already mentioned homework. Now,
this is supposed to be one sixth,
but I know I don't want any
transcendental numbers here.
So, I made it 16.75 exactly.
So, it's roughly one sixth for the
homework. That's the average of all
of your weekly quizzes in the
recitation. Each of those three
monthly tests gives also a sixth.
So, one plus three is four, four
sixths, which leaves two
sixths, or one third.
So, the final is worth 33%,
all right? So, that's the breakdown.
And, the grade is C level,
and it's based upon a performance of
50% absolute. I want you to learn;
I do not have you compete against
your classmates.
There is no curving of the grades,
OK, no curving of the grades. How
do I know that that's an absolute
pass, though? Well,
when we set the exams,
we set the tests, I sit with my TA's
and we say, all right,
let's work out the point scheme on
this question.
Let's say it's worth ten points.
I say, well, let's grade about five
or six of them,
maybe ten of them,
get a sense of it. If a person has
the basic concept down,
regardless of numerical errors,
if the person has the basic concept
down, he or she must get at least
five out of ten.
If the person has not mastered the
basic concept,
the person must fail,
must get four or less.
And, if that's not the case,
then we redo the point scheme,
all right?
So, if you propagate that through
the whole year,
and you have the basic mastery of
the concepts, 50 is a pass.
That's the way we do it, no grading
on a curve. But,
I also look at trends.
To show you the kind of attention
you get in this class,
on the 17th, Friday the 17th,
I know where I and my staff will be.
We are going to be in a conference
room not far from here,
and we are going to be reviewing
every person's performance in this
class. We're going to go
down the whole list.
And, what we looking for?
We are looking for trends.
We're looking for trends.
Obviously, if your aggregate score
is 75, you're passed.
But, I'm looking at what's going on
in the vicinity of 50 because I
don't think my point scheme is that
accurate. So,
suppose I have somebody who comes in
here with a shaky background in
chemistry from high school and gets
a failing score on the first test,
and works hard and improves, but
still fails the second test,
passes the third test, writes a
decent final, and has an
aggregate score of 48.
I have the freedom to pass that
person because I like the trend.
Suppose I have somebody else who
came here with two years of
chemistry in high school,
got a 95 on the first test,
70 on the second test, failed the
third test, failed the final,
has an aggregate score of 48. I'll
let that person sit there because
that person clearly didn't make the
investment. That person didn't take
ownership of his or her education.
That person isn't deciding to be a
part of the 3.091 community.
In fact, if that person has a 48 and
the first person who had the weaker
score has a 46,
I could still pass the person with
the 46, and fail the person with the
48. If I want to,
I can give the person with the 46 an
A. I can do anything I want because
I'm the professor.
[LAUGHTER] [APPLAUSE] What else I
can do, there's no requirement for
me to fail anybody.
My management doesn't ask me what
I'm doing in here,
all right? They don't know.
They really don't. So, if
everybody masters the material,
I can say A's on the house. They
don't say to me,
six bodies, one of them must fail.
No, so, my point is that I want you
to succeed, and I know you can
succeed. Faculty here have three
major professional activities.
One is teaching.
One is research.
And the third is administration.
We serve on committees. Well, for
the last three years I've been
chairing the committee on
undergraduate admissions and
financial aid.
I chaired the committee at the time
you were applying.
I read some of your folders.
I sat at the selection period where
we've got the stacks: 11,
00 applications. You went through a
grueling screening process.
I know the quality of individual in
this room. I sat there.
It was during the Patriot's Day,
no, the President's Day weekend,
sitting here Friday,
Saturday, Sunday, Monday,
stacks of them going: yes,
no, hell no. [LAUGHTER] See,
tenure means never having to say
you're sorry. So,
you're here. 11,000,
and you made it. And I know that
everybody in this room,
first of all, belongs here.
Everybody in this room has the
intellectual apparatus not to just
pass 3.091, but to
flourish in 3.091.
And, I want you to succeed.
The only people who fail 3.
91 are those who choose to fail 3.
91. They choose not to come to
class. They choose not to work the
homework. They choose not to
interact with the recitation
instructors. I don't know why they
make that choice.
The website: the website has all
sorts of goodies including the
readings. You've got to read before
you come to class.
I'm not going to write them on the
board like a little high school
teacher. I'm not doing that anymore.
You are taking ownership.
So, you go the website. The other
thing you will find on the website
are old homeworks,
old exams, all sorts of resources,
and they are videotaping this. By
the way, they are videotaping it in
a sort of heightened technology this
year. And so,
some of this is going to end up on
Open Courseware.
So, if any of you doesn't want to
be, by chance,
seen on the Internet,
then sit out of range of the camera.
I guess that's all I can tell you.
So, that's why there's all these
cameras here. So,
you can click on this.
It's On Demand. So, if you by
chance, I know it's very rare,
but if by chance you don't get the
class you can always follow up later.
It's also on a vernier,
a sliding scale. So, if there is
one section of the lecture that I
went a little too quickly for,
you could say, gee, if I could just
see that five minutes,
you could click on it, zoom into
that five minutes,
play it a few times,
and then say, I still don't know
what he's talking about.
And then you go to a recitation
instructor. So,
this is what happens.
You go to the website,
there's all these bars down the side,
so there's lecture videos.
There is lecture topics. That's
where the readings are.
And, there's a whole bunch of other
information there,
and then a list of recitation
instructors. So,
here's the reading.
So, for example today,
there is a vision statement,
administrative details and I'm going
to get a little bit of teaching
towards the end.
And, if you wanted to,
you could crack the book and look at
chapter one. So, that's the drill.
But, again, that's up to you.
A couple of topics, a little bit
unpleasant, but we have to cover
them. The management doesn't care
what I say in terms of chemistry.
But, they really care about this
stuff. So, I'm going to obey.
So, academic honesty: very simply,
you can't cheat in 3.091. Is that
shocking? No cheating! You know
this. The Roman poet philosopher
Juvenal said men need not so much be
informed as reminded.
You know this.
I'm telling you nothing new.
So, when you take a test, you don't
accept information from others.
You don't represent as your own
work the work of anyone else,
and you don't use aids to memory
other than those permitted by the
examiner. I'm giving you an aid
sheet. You've got the table of
constants. What else do you need?
It's enough. And, following a test,
a lot of people write in pencil:
don't try to erase something and
bring it back and say that,
oh, actually, this is what I had
because we look at that and
go, this is perfect.
How do we miss something like that?
Don't do that. And, also, we're
trying to teach you on many levels.
We're trying to teach you some
chemistry, but I'm also trying to
teach you how to transform into a
standalone professional.
In the code of conduct,
professional conduct,
that we embody by this code here is
comparable to what you are expected
to adhere to in your
professional lives.
You don't publish results that
you've faked. You don't publish
results that you stole from others
and represented as your own.
So, don't start here. And, it
happens infrequently,
but I've got to tell you,
a few years back on the final exam,
a couple of people were involved in
passing information back and forth.
They got caught. You know why they
got caught? Because for the first
time, you're being taught by people
who are smart as you are.
So, you're going to get caught.
My TA's are really smart. So,
don't think it's like back in,
pick a place, I could offend
somebody. It's not like we're back
in Ontario, how's that?
That's where I came from.
You're here now. So, don't try it.
You're going to get caught. These
guys got caught.
I had to press the case to the
committee on discipline.
One of them did not return for his
sophomore year. That's
a crazy thing to do.
It's a huge price to pay in a
pass-no-record first semester class.
And, you know who is most severe on
the committee on discipline?
It's made of faculty,
administrators,
and students. And,
guess who the most severe members of
that committee are?
It's the students, your peers who
are outraged at that kind of
behavior. Speaking of behavior,
I have to maintain a fertile
learning environment in here.
We've got round numbers in excess
of 400 people sitting here,
so I expect certain things here,
and that's how we're going to get
along.
First of all, no conversations,
no talking. A little conversation
here, a little conversation there,
it adds up. So, I insist, no
talking. Please,
no food or drink. No food or drink.
We're seated cheek to jowl here. I
don't want somebody opening up a
clamshell with some hot food in it.
It's not right. It's not right.
Plus, there's all kinds of trash
left around. Nobody
picks up the stuff.
Now, this is an exception.
This is for medicinal purposes.
It's to make sure that my throat
doesn't get dry.
And, I swear, it really contains
Fresca. And, of course,
no disruptive behavior, no
disruptive behavior.
Wireless communication devices must
be silenced. So,
from this moment forth,
and I heard some stuff go off
earlier.
But, I let it slide because I
haven't had my chance to explain
what my expectations are.
But, from this moment forth,
cell phone goes off, you're out.
You leave the room, OK? And, Lord
help you if a cell phone goes off
during an exam because those things
have text messaging capabilities.
If your cell phone goes off during
an exam, I come up there.
I grab your paper, I tear it in
half, and I give you a zero.
I am teaching you professional
behavior. That's unprofessional.
You can say that I'm over the top on
this. I've got 450 people.
I want to maintain a fertile
learning environment.
When you walk through that door,
it's an act of free will. It's an
act of free will.
Somebody's leaving.
Bye. Let's go. Let's get it
started right now.
Please. It makes noise when you
turn it off?
You owe these gals dinner,
I tell you. All right, turn them
off. If they have to make noise as
you turn them off,
turn them off, but that's it.
So, when you walk through that door,
it's an act of free will.
And, we enter into a contract.
You walk in here, you have certain
expectations of me.
You expect me to conduct myself
professionally.
You expect me to respect you.
You expect me not to use foul
language. You expect me not to say
offensive things to you.
You expect me to have a
well-prepared lecture.
Well, you know what? I have
expectations of you.
I expect you to come to class
prepared. I expect you to sit there
quietly, respect your neighbors.
I expect you to contribute to the
learning environment.
That's not unreasonable,
is it? Good.
You ever look in the course bulletin?
You ever wonder what this is?
This is the listing for 3.091,
5-0-7. Five hours is contact time.
That's three hours here, and two
hours with the recitation instructor.
Zero, there's no lab.
Seven, I wonder what the seven is?
That must be the time you spend in
preparation in studying.
So, I make a pledge. You give me
seven hours a week,
you will pass this class,
not just by the skin of your teeth.
You will pass it.
If you don't give me seven hours a
week, I don't know what I can do for
you. So, I want you to be
successful. So,
I put this up. This is sort of
venues for learning: recitation,
reading, homework, so, that's my
responsibility,
the lecture. Recitation: that's got
to be the staff.
You, you're responsible for the
reading. You're responsible for the
homework, the quizzes,
the tests, the final exam.
So, what we have here is a
partnership, a partnership
in learning.
What we want is for you to grow.
Franklin said education is what
remains when you've forgotten all
your schooling.
So, we want you to have some
retention here.
So, we've got a few minutes here.
I don't want you to just have you
go from room to room with people
saying, welcome to MIT.
So, I want to talk a little bit
about taxonomy, classification,
nomenclature.
I said at the core blitz that one of
the things I'm going to try to do is
introduce some things from beyond
chemistry. So,
let's see what the Bard had to say
about nomenclature.
There may even be people here who
distinguished themselves because
they starred in Romeo and Juliet.
Or, maybe they produced. Maybe
they built the sets.
Maybe they wrote the screenplay.
I don't know. So, let's look, Act
II Scene II. You remember this,
Romeo: "but soft, what light through
yonder window breaks.
It is the east, and Juliet is the
sun."
That has nothing to do with
nomenclature, nothing.
Photon emission, perhaps.
OK, let's get to nomenclature.
Juliet: "oh Romeo, Romeo, wherefore
art thou Romeo?
Deny thy father and refuse they
name, or if thou wilt not,
be but sworn, my love, and I'll no
longer be a Capulet.
She's a Capulet. He's a Montague,
you know, like the Hatfields and the
McCoys, the warring families,
two lovers, it's as old as
literature that's here.
OK, so now, Romeo: "shall I hear
more, or shall I speak at this?
Fellows, a bit of advice, don't
interrupt. The answer to that
question is, no,
don't speak. So,
Juliet: "'tis but thy name that is
my enemy. Thou art thyself,
though not a Montague. What's
Montague? It is nor hand nor foot
nor arm nor face nor any other part
belonging to a man.
Oh, be some other name.
What's in a name? That which we
call a rose by any other word would
smell as sweet.
So Romeo would,
were he not Romeo called.
Retain that dear perfection which
he owes without that title.
Romeo, doff thy name, and for that
name, which is no part of thee,
take all myself." That's an offer.
In science, it works differently.
In science, we have to agree. It
can't be like Alice in Wonderland.
I'll give the word the meaning I
intend it to mean.
Science has to have some rigor.
So, if you look in chapter one, you
will find these definitions for
different atomic groupings starting
down here with the elements and
moving through up through complex
matter. This is solid state up here,
aggregates of atoms.
So, we're going to begin down in the
lower left corner.
We're going to begin in the lower
left corner. So,
let's look at some of the origins of
chemistry. We can go back to
ancient Egypt where there is
reference in the hieroglyphs to term
khemeia, which,
among other things,
meant chemical processes for
embalming the dead.
You know, the Egyptians were very
concerned about afterlife?
They wanted to be well preserved to
make that journey.
So, practitioners who understood
what we would know to be chemistry
were highly valued in that society.
And then, you may expand it to other
chemical processes,
dyeing of cloth, glassmaking,
and metals extraction. It's magical.
It's sorcery to take an ore and
convert it to metal.
It's magic. It still amazes me
today. Gee, you know,
I showed you this earlier.
One of my areas is extraction of
metals.
You know, some things never change.
And then, they tried to make an
overarching theme,
an overarching theme,
to go to the heavens. So,
there were seven known metals at the
time, and seven heavenly bodies.
So, obviously, the sun would be
gold. Mercury is a liquid metal,
and mercury, the planet, is the
fastest moving naked eye heavenly
body. Mars, iron, why is Mars red?
Iron oxide. And,
in fact, you can even couch things.
So, if I wanted to make a bronze,
which is an alloy of tin and copper,
I could say the confluence of Venus
with Jupiter, and that way keep it
so that the common folk would know
the secret of the alloy.
So, now, let's look at the
transition from craft to science,
craft to science. About 2,400 years
ago, we have Democritus.
And, Democritus moves from practice
to theory.
And, this is all that was known at
that time, seven metals,
carbon, and sulfur. And so,
here was his idea of the structure
of matter. It's about 400 B.
. And, what did Democritus do?
He described the physical world as
the integral of void plus being.
He used lofty terms.
And, being he described as an
infinity of indivisible particles,
which he dubbed atoms from the Greek.
Tomi means to slice,
and A as in apolitical,
amoral, so a-tomi is something that
is indivisible,
cannot be sliced.
And, he says these are eternal.
And, in between,
there is void, which is very similar
to how we would describe vacuum.
This is 2,400 years ago. This
depiction of matter takes you right
up to E=MC squared.
Brilliant. And, that's all he had
to work with for data.
That's all he had to work with.
But, science doesn't always move
forward. After that came Aristotle.
And, Aristotle gave us this system,
which persisted almost through the
Middle Ages. And,
Aristotle gave us this,
and I'll leave you with this.
And, you can ponder. So, this is
the Aristotelian view.
He's got four essences: Earth,
fire, water, air.
You could even make compounds: Earth
plus water makes cold.
I mean, this is nuts. This is nuts.
But it was there for over a
thousand years,
and we now know things to be a
little different.
And so what I'm going to do the
next day is return to this
discussion, and take a look at a
more rational view of the chemical
world. So, we'll see you on Friday.